Before you start going bananas
on using arrow functions, let's
go through a couple examples of
when you probably don't want an
arrow function. All of these are
just going to boil down to not
having the keyword "this," but
they are just different use
cases that you'd run into. First
of all, I've got this button.
It's a big a button that says, "
Push me." When someone pushes
or clicks that button, I want to
toggle the class of "on," which
should turn it yellow, "on and
off," "on and off." I said I've
grabbed the button with
selector here,
and then I listen for a click on
that button. When someone clicks
that button, I'm going to run
this following function. It
gives us this error, "TypeError,
cannot read property 'toggle' of
undefined." What does that mean?
Well, let's just "console.log"
this. What is this going to be?
I'm going pause here. Hopefully,
you're yelling at the screen
right now. It's a window, right?
Remember, we talked about if you
use an arrow function, the
keyword "this" is not bound to
that actual function. We don't
actually know what got clicked,
because we use an arrow function
there. We don't want to use a
function there. Take that arrow
out. We're to choose a regular
old function which will allow "
this" to be equal to the actual
button. Console.log "this" is
now equal to the button, and our
beautiful clicker is actually
working. Now, let's take a look
at this next one, when you need
a method to bind to an object.
Here we've got a "person." We've
got this method here, it's
called "score" and whenever we
call "person.score," it's going
to just increment the number
inside of it, so we've got 23.
Let's see what we've got here.
If we just say "person," what
have we got? We've got points is
equal to 23. If we say "person.
score," run it once, two. Let's
run it three times. We should be
at 26 now. If I say "person,"
it's still at 23. Why? We'll
just do the same thing. What is
this going to be equal to inside
of a function that has been an
arrow function? Go to window.
Exactly, right? We do not want
to use "this" here. You want to
use a regular function, which
will give us the actual "person."
There we go. That will actually
work, 24. You might be screaming
at me right now saying, "Even
better." We haven't talked about
this yet, but there is a
function or an object
improvement here, where when you
have a method on an object, you
can simply just type that. Now,
we're going to go into a little
bit more, but let's just look
ahead. We could have also used
that. That is equivalent to just
a regular type "dot function,"
not an arrow function. Next up,
we have this, when you need to
add a prototype method. Here,
I've got a class. We haven't
learned about classes, but just
know that this is a way for us
to make new cars. I have this
class constructor where, when
you call "new Car," we pass it
the type of Car, as well as the
color of the Car. I can say the
bima is a BMW that is blue. The
subie is a Subaru that is white.
Let's go ahead and look at them.
I'll say subie, there we go, is
a Subaru that's white. A bima is
a BMW that's blue. Now, after
the fact, I added on this
prototype method, and what that
allows us to do is that, even
after these things have been
created, we can add methods onto
all of them. I say car.prototype.
summarize, which will allow me
to do things like subie.
summarize. You see that it's
auto-completing it there,
because it's available to me.
Even though I added it after we
created the Car, because I added
it to the prototype, it's
available in every object that
has been created from there.
What this prototype does is it
returns "this.make" which is the
make that we passed in, and "
this.color," in a sentence. But
when you call it, "this.car" is
undefined and the color
undefined. Why is that? It's
because we try to be cool. We
try to be a bit of a hot shot
here by using an arrow function.
Again, why don't we use an arrow
function here? Because we
explicitly need the keyword "
this," so a regular function
would do. Give that a
save. Now, if we call subie.
summarize, it says it's a white.
We call bima.summarize, we get
BMW in blue. Again, using a
regular function for that. Then,
finally, this is a little bit
different. It doesn't have to do
with the keyword "this," but we
don't have access to the
Arguments object when you use an
arrow function. This is helpful
for when you want to run a
function like, right here, this
function is going to take
unlimited arguments. It might
take one, it might take 100.
It's going to just say like, "
This child was born first."
Here's an example, older
children, I'm passing in, "Jill"
as a first argument, "Wes" as a
second argument, and "Jana" as a
third argument. When I run it,
it says, "ReferenceError,
arguments is not defined."
Arguments is a keyword that we
have in JavaScript that's going
to give us an array or array-ish
value of everything that was
passed in. One, two, three items,
and you do not get the Arguments
object if you use an arrow
function when you use a regular
function, which is going to give
us the actual content that we
need. Again, go through all
those really quickly. Make sure
that you aren't just using arrow
functions willy-nilly. In
general, if you do not need the
Arguments object or you do not
need "this," or you know that
you will not need it in the
future, then you can feel free
to go ahead and use an arrow
function on everything else.